Hỏi các hàng nhìn của đất đã đổ op xuống đường khi nhiều uốt tô sẽ mấy đang trải lên xa pa.
Sư việc xây ra sáng bốn thân tám tại tuyến đường giận lên cầu mống sến,
nối với cút lộ bốn đe, và qua sả tạp viên, lâu cây.
Quảng 3 nghìn mệt khối đất đã từ vách nối cao hàng chục mệt sạch xuống,
phụ kiến mặt đường và hết độ hàng giao phân lần, gần trạp phụ phi bều đe.
Nếu sẽ kiến thoát khỏi vùng sặt lợ, mấy mắn không có thương vang.
Một phụ đổ chất luôn nếu trả nế qua nè mặt đường,
đi hoàn hình hình hình không đi và đi gặp tích lực kỳ phó đồ hãi
thì mạng em vẫn nàn phó thông dạc mệt là nối, đẩm tình thống chơi, cho đi đường.
Lần lượng chức năng phóng toại hiện trường, phân lộng xe và huy động mấy móc giọng đất đã.
Dưới đường này, kết nối cao tốt nội bài lòng kai với cút lộ bốn đe,
cách xa pa khoảng 12 kỳ lộ mẹ.
Mời lưỡn kéo dài hai ngày qua, khiến nhiều cút vực ở lòng kai nập sâu,
về thẻ thải về thải sản và hòa mồ.
Theo chúng tâm dự vào khi tượng khi văn cuốc gia,
từ chio bốn tháng tắm đến đêm sấu tháng tắm,
bắt bộ và mắt chung bộ,
kết thục có bữa tò đến rất tò,
làm ra tăng quy cơ lúc quét và sát lời đất.